la crise syrienne a causé la plus grande
crise migratoire depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale
en fait c'est une crise humanitaire
d'une ampleur jamais vue en train en
bateau à pied c'est plus de 4 millions
personnes qui sont jetés sur les routes
de l'exil à la recherche d'une nouvelle
vie mais surtout une porte d'entrée vers
l'europe terre promise
l'art principales empruntées par les
migrants passe entre autres par la
méditerranée les migrants traversent la
turquie pour ensuite tenter de relier
par la mer une des îles grecques et
ainsi entrer dans l'union européenne et
poursuivre ensuite leur route à travers
les balkans
ils vont traverser plusieurs pays de
transit dans l'espoir d'atteindre les
pays européens les plus prisées comme
l'allemagne la suède ou le royaume uni
les obstacles et les dangers sont
présents partout passeur criminels
frontières fermées mur de protection des
mesures qui n'empêche toutefois pas des
milliers de personnes ont tenté de fuir
chaque jour va pays déchiré par une
guerre civile interminable